Amen. Well, good morning, church. Uh, my name is Trr Lewis.
It's a pleasure to get to be with you this morning. Um,
I get to serve as one of the elders here at Henderson Hills and when we get to
teach, it's a special pleasure. Um, bring your greetings from the elder council.
We meet every other Tuesday night and pray for our church family,
both specifically and just in general for needs. And that's a huge, um,
privilege of our to get to do in honor, um,
and welcome on Memorial Day. Uh, we do wanna remember today,
we wanna remember those who have served our country in the military. Um,
we wanna remember you all who may have family members that are serving right
now, um, and those who have lost loved ones, family and friends,
uh, to military service. So I wanna take a moment this morning to pray,
pray for us to that end. And then as we open God's word, father,
this morning we, um, open your word to read about your spirit.
Your spirit poured out to your sons and daughters.
And we know that your spirit moves in so many mighty ways. Father,
one of those is through comforter, through healer. And so, father,
we pray that this morning for those who are remembering those whom they've lost,
we thank you for the sacrifice, the example, um, that they set in that of,
of sacrificing themselves, um, for others,
just as you did for us Father. And this morning, as we open your word,
I pray that your spirit would speak, Lord, not through the notes on the page,
but Father, um, into the hearts of those who hear.
It's in Christ's name we pray. Amen. Okay, well,
um, it is a pleasure to get to be here. Um, I,
I signed up for the Sunday after Heath Thomas,
cuz I thought he might have left some of his hair products backstage,
and he didn't, unfortunately. So, um,
so here we are this morning,
but this is Pentecost Sunday and Pentecost Sunday is a Sunday in the
church calendar where we recognize and we
observe.
We remember the coming of the Holy Spirit on the disciples
in Jerusalem. And it's a time for us to,
to reflect and to see how the Holy Spirit's been at work. Now,
my wife and I have been at members of Henderson Hills here for about 19 years.
And several years ago we were, um,
a part of serving a meal at the college house, um, with our community group,
or it may have been a flock at the time, I can't remember in that transition.
But I was there and we would hang around and visit with the college students
after the meal. And they would, uh, ask questions.
We would talk about their major and career aspirations.
And this one Sunday night, this one, uh, student from the Middle East,
we were sitting on the porch, I still remember it clear as day. And he said,
you know, I know about this God, I've heard people talk about him. Um, I,
people have told me about Jesus, but what is the Holy Spirit?
What is the Holy Spirit?
And so I'm certain that I fumbled through some answer. And we, we talked for,
for some time, um, and I,
I pray that the word used some of those words to water seeds in his life.
And he seemed fairly content with the answer. And so we parted ways.
But I've thought about that question in the year since that it's probably been a
decade both about that question, but also the motivation of the question.
And the first thing I wanna do this morning is to rephrase that question,
not what is the Holy Spirit, but who is the Holy Spirit?
That's our question this morning. Who is the Holy Spirit?
And as we open the text, we're gonna see him move.
And then we're gonna look throughout Scripture at his actions and attributes.
We see today that the Holy Spirit is God, the Trinity,
the Holy Spirit is part of the Trinity. He's God with us.
Now, the earliest,
earliest writings about the Trinity were from this guy named Tetuan,
which is a cool name to say. And also he was from Tunisia,
which is in Northern Africa, which is a whole nother, a whole nother deal.
But he, he, he put together the different, um,
parts of scripture that talk about God the Father, God the Son,
and God the Spirit, and develop this doctrine of the Trinity
thousands of years ago in about one 50 ad.
And so we see the Trinity at work throughout scripture,
and today we're gonna focus on that person of the Holy Spirit.
One particular verse, we'll come back to you later, but we see in Titus three,
uh, verses four through six, he says,
but when the goodness and loving kindness of our God, our Savior appeared,
he saved us not because of works and righteousness,
but according to his own mercy by the washing
and regeneration and renewal of the Holy Spirit,
whom he poured out on us richly through Jesus Christ our Savior.
So we see the Father of the Son and the Holy Spirit all working together,
God three in one. And as followers of Christ,
we should know who is the Holy Spirit.
We should be intimately acquainted with him because there are,
there are myriad of misrepresentations and countless confusions about who he is
and how we are to relate to him. Now, for the last five weeks,
we've walked through the book of Joel,
the prophecy of the Day of the Lord coming.
And we read in Joel 2 28 through 30, it says,
and it shall come to pass afterward that I will pour out my spirit on
all flesh. Your sons and your daughter shall prophesy.
Your old men shall dream dreams.
Your young men shall see visions even on the male and female servants.
In those days, I will pour out my spirit
that there has come, we are in that time.
We live in the age of that fulfillment when the Holy Spirit has been poured out
to us. And so let's turn today, acts chapter two.
We're gonna read of that time in scripture where the Holy Spirit came on and was
poured out on the disciples at Pentecost.
Now obviously we cannot answer fully
who is the Holy Spirit today, but we're gonna look at three key things.
We're gonna look at his appearance when he appeared, when he came on the scene.
We're gonna look at his attributes, both in the Old and New Testament,
and also at his actions. So let's turn in Acts two.
So we see this Pentecost, it's the Feast of Weeks.
It's a time where people have gathered in Jerusalem.
It's a time where they came to celebrate the harvest,
celebrate the first fruits with a sacrifice.
And so Jews were gathered from all over the known world at that time to
Jerusalem. It was a huge celebration.
And we read Luke's words in Acts chapter two. He says,
when the day of Pentecost arrived, they were all gathered together in one place.
And suddenly there came from heaven, a sound like a mighty rushing wind.
And it filled the entire house where they were sitting and divided tongues of
fire appeared to them and rested on each one of them.
And they were filled with the Holy Spirit and began to speak in other tongues as
the Spirit gave them utterance. Now, there were dwelling in Jerusalem,
Jews devout men from every nation under heaven. And at this sound,
a multitude came together and they were bewildered because each one was hearing
them speak in his own language. And they were amazed and astonished saying,
are not all these speaking Galilean?
And how is it that we hear each of us in our own native language,
Parthians and meads, elamites and resonance of Mesopotamia,
Judea, OCIA Ponta in Asia, Faria Phi, Egypt,
and the parts of Egypt belonging to cyrene visitors from Rome,
both Jews and Proselytes Creon Arabian.
We hear them telling in our own tongues, the mighty works of God
and all we're amazed saying to one another, what does this mean?
But others mock them saying they're filled with new wine.
So this scene happens when God has created an atmosphere for his spirit to move.
He's brought people in to hear this message. He's prepared the place.
And Jesus had commanded his disciples to stay.
You could imagine that in this time,
this probably wasn't the most comfortable place for the disciples to be.
There were Jews coming from all over the world. But just a chapter before,
just before his ascension,
Christ says he ordered them not to depart from Jerusalem, but to wait,
to wait for the promise from the Father, in which he said,
you heard from me for John baptized with water,
but you'll be baptized with the Holy Spirit.
Not many days from now.
Now this had been 10 days from the time that he spoke these words.
So the time from, uh, Passover to Pentecost was 50 days.
We read in Acts one that the Lord in his, um,
in his resurrection body before the ascension was with the disciples for 40
days, right? So even we can do the math,
that's 10 days that the disciples were waiting and they were probably ready,
right? They were probably ready for this gift, for this Holy Spirit to come.
You can imagine that they had enthusiasm, but it might have started to wane.
They may have even started to question when or if this Holy Spirit might come.
And so they were gathered, they were praying,
and then suddenly Luke riots, like a mighty rushing wind from heaven,
the Spirit came in and filled the house,
but he didn't just fill the house above them.
It says he divided into individual tongues of fire and appeared to them and
rested individually on each one of them and filled the, filled them,
filled the disciples. So when the spirit comes,
he comes in power and he comes individually to Phyllis.
We see them in the Spirit, begin to speak in different languages.
They're able to communicate these mighty works of God in a new way.
You see, when the spirit's poured out, he creates connection and community.
He's a, he's given new abilities to these disciples of Christ to speak.
And we see that he's empowering the message.
And we see later that he will embolden them then to go.
And you see the disciples were ready for this.
They were anticipating this work of the Spirit.
John Jesus had been teaching back in John.
We read John 14 and in 16 about the promise of the Holy Spirit.
And then just before he left, he told them to wait.
And so they had been anticipating this gift, this gift of the helper.
So they were looking what God would do. But you see,
the rest of the world wasn't ready
just as the world wasn't ready for Jesus. And many missed the Messiah.
The people gathered, the Jews gathered there, weren't ready for the Holy Spirit.
But we want to be ready. We want to know the spirit.
We want to be able to recognize him at work.
We wanna know properly what is the spirit at work and what is not the spirit at
work. So we're gonna spend some time this morning looking at his actions and his
attributes. You see, there's a,
there's a level of subjectivity and objectivity. Okay?
There's subjectivity where we feel the spirit, we see a move,
but then there's objectivity of seeing the spirit in the word.
And we're gonna do both this morning.
But I wanna start with looking at the word because that lays our foundation for
who God is.
And then that allows us to look at the actions and see is that the spirit at
work around us.
The other reality is that when we study something, we see it around us, right?
If there's something that we study, that we know if we're,
if we're shopping for something new, if you're looking for a new, um,
Honda Accord, right?
Then you notice all the Honda Accords on the road around you. And if you're,
if you're, if you've noticed or been exposed to a new flavor or a new spice,
then, then you start to taste that in foods.
Maybe you hadn't tasted it in before.
And so we want to gather an appreciation this morning. So if it,
if it feels academic for a minute, as we walk through some scripture, uh,
rest in that and uh, and and,
and take notes of scripture to go back and look at, and this is just a taste,
so that as you start to look through scripture,
we're gonna see the spirit more and more at work.
So let's look at his attributes.
So we talked earlier that the Spirit is God, the Holy Spirit is God.
And so any attribute of God that we would say applies to the Spirit,
father, son and spirit all have the same attributes.
They display their divinity in different ways and at different times,
but they all have those attributes.
So let's look at omniscience as an attribute.
We know that we would say God is omniscient. He is all knowing.
And Paul writes in one Corinthians chapter two, verse nine, he says,
but as it is written, what no I has seen nor ear has heard,
nor the heart of man imagined what God has prepared for those who love him.
These things God has revealed to us through the Spirit,
for the spirit searches everything,
even the depths of God for who knows a person's thoughts except the spirit of
that person which is in him. So also,
no one comprehends the thoughts of God except the spirit of God.
You see friends, the spirit is all know him. He's also omnipresent.
He's everywhere. In Psalm 1 39,
the famous song from David, he sings,
where shall I go from your Spirit? Or Where shall I flee from your presence?
If I ascend to the heaven, you are there. If I make my bed and shield,
you are there.
If I take on the wings of the morning and dwell on the uttermost of the sea,
even there your hand shall lead me, and your right hand shall hold me.
Holy Spirit is everywhere. We can't escape his presence.
He's also omnipotent the spirit's all powerful.
Paul writes to us in Romans 15, he says,
I will not venture to speak of anything except what Christ has accomplished
through me to bring the Gentiles to obedience by word and by deed,
by the power of signs and wonders,
by the power of the Holy Spirit of God.
So that from Jerusalem and all the way around to a rium,
I will have fulfilled the ministry of the gospel of Christ.
And you see together,
Paul is linking the ministry and the power of Christ with the ministry and the
power of the Spirit because they're inseparable.
Both are all powerful.
Next we would say that God is holy. Well, that's easy.
It's right there in the name Holy Spirit, right?
We see that the Lord is sovereign. Our God is sovereign. He is in control.
We see the spirit's sovereignty played out in one Corinthians 12, verse 11,
where he says, he gives gifts to believers as he apportions,
as he wills in the Old Testament. In first Samuel,
we see his sovereignty played out as the Holy Spirit rushes on
Saul in his anointing as the first king of Israel,
the Holy Spirit is eternal. The writer of Hebrews identifies him in verse nine,
in chapter nine, verse 14, as the eternal Spirit,
holy Spirit is loving. And second Samuel, chapter seven,
he's speaking of David. And he says, I will be to him a father,
and he shall be to my son, to be to me a son. When he commits iniquity,
I will discipline him with a rot of men, with the stripes of the sons of men.
But my steadfast love will not depart from him.
And then Paul in Romans five,
tells us about our hope. And he says,
this hope does not put us to shame because God's love has been poured into our
hearts through the Holy Spirit.
That the Holy Spirit is love in the same way. God is love.
And he pours that into our hearts. Holy Spirit is gracious.
We see that in one Corinthians 12 where it says,
no one can say that Jesus' Lord, except in the Spirit,
it's by his grace.
It's through his graciousness even that we can say that he is Lord.
He speaks to our spirit, he calls our spirit and he gives us life.
The Holy Spirit is steadfast. He's always with us. He never leaves.
In Ephesians one, Paul writes in him, you also,
when you heard the word of truth,
the gospel of your salvation and believed in him,
you were sealed with a promised Holy Spirit who is the guarantee of our
inheritance until we acquire possession of it to the praise of His glory.
So we see through all these attributes,
these are attributes that we would describe to God the Father, God the Son,
and also God, the Spirit. So if there's anything that we take away from today,
we should know that the Spirit is God. He's not heir,
he's not a figment, he's not a ghost.
He is personal and he is personable. He is knowable.
Now, this side of heaven, we can't know him perfectly,
but he does know us perfectly and he breathes into us.
So let's look at the actions of the spirit. What's he doing?
What is the spirit doing?
We don't have to go very far into scripture until we see the spirit. In fact,
in Genesis, in Genesis chapter one,
we see the spirit in creation says in the beginning,
God created the heavens in the earth.
The earth was without form and void and darkness was over the face of the deep.
And the spirit of God was hovering over the face of the
waters. You see, it's the spirit of God that was there and moving.
He's hovering over the creation that he's about to create
in later. In that, in in, in that same chapter, in verse 27 26,
we see this famous creation verse Genesis 1 26, where he says,
let us make man in our image, in our likeness.
And many times we, we put God the Father and God the Son,
together in that narrative. And that is very true. And God,
the Spirit is there just as much. We read later in, in Genesis two,
that he breathed life into Adam.
He was the breath of life.
David sings this out in his psalms and Psalm 33 where he says the word
made the heavens and the breath, the Spirit made the host. And then Psalm 1 0 4,
he says, when the breath is taken away, there's death.
But when the spirit is sent, it creates life.
And so we see this breath of God, this breathing out this action of the spirit.
And that's why the study of the Holy Spirit is called nematology. Now,
we didn't put that on the notes because nobody would've come,
but nematology is the study of the spirit. It's the study of the breath of God.
Christology, the study of Christ, pathology, the study of the Father,
and nematology the study of the Spirit.
So in a moment, at the end of the service,
when we're singing about the breath of our lungs singing out, praise to God,
that's the Holy Spirit in us. That's the breath of God.
That's the new life in us.
We read later in Ezekiel, uh, chapter 37, about him not only giving,
but also sustaining and creating new life.
So if you'll turn into Ezekiel 37, we're gonna read that
now. If you get an Old Testament scholar, PhD, you get Old Testament.
If you get a bone doctor, you get bones, right?
So we're gonna read Ezekiel 37. It says,
the hand of the Lord was upon me and he brought me out in the
spirit of the Lord and sent me down in the middle of the valley
and it was full of bones. And he led me around among them.
And behold,
there were very many on the surface of the valley and they were very dry.
And he said to me, son of man, can these bones live? And I answered,
oh Lord, you know? Then he said to me,
prophesy over these bones and say to them, oh, dry bones,
hear the word of the Lord, thus says the Lord God to these bones,
behold that will cause breath to enter into you and you will live.
And I will a sinews upon you and cause flesh to come upon you and cover you with
skin and put breath in you and you shall live.
And you shall know that I am the Lord. Ezekiel continues to write, he says.
So I prophesied and I commanded. And as I prophesied,
there was a sound and behold a rattling. And the bones came together,
bone to bone. And I looked behold,
and there were sinews on them and flesh came upon them and skin had covered
them, but there was no breath in them. And then he said to me,
prophesy to the breath, prophesy son a man and say to the breath,
thus says the Lord God
come from the four wins of breath and breathe on these slain that they may live.
So I prophesied as the Lord commanded me,
and the breath came into them and they lived and stood on their feet and
exceedingly great army. And then he said to me, son of man,
these bones are the whole house of Israel. Behold, they say,
our bones are dried up. Our hope is lost. Indeed, we are cut off,
therefore prophesy and say to them, thus says the Lord, behold,
I will open your graves and I will raise your graves on my people,
and I will bring you into the land of Israel.
You shall know that I'm the Lord when I open your graves and raise your graves
on my people. I will put my spirit in you and you shall live,
and I will place you in your own land.
And then you shall know that I am the Lord. I have spoken. I will do it,
declares the Lord.
Now that's a long passage about the Spirit speaking to
Ezekiel and then moving through as a breath of life into these dry bones.
And, and the Spirit then takes me into Ephesians two,
where Paul writes that we were dead in our transgressions,
but praise God that we've been given new and sustaining life through the Spirit.
We also read that the Holy Spirit inspires holiness in that new life.
We're called to live holy lives, p uh,
David and and Psalm 1 43 Rights, teach me to do your will. Oh God,
let your good spirit lead me on level ground.
We see the old, the the Old Testament example of the spirit giving strength,
giving power for special things at special times. And judges,
we studied that several years ago about Samson and Gideon and Deborah,
all receiving the spirit to do the mighty works of God.
We see the spirit of God anointing and leading through Saul and through David.
We see him coming and going in these men's lives for
his will and for God's glory.
In Isaiah,
we read that the Spirit will rest on the Messiah in chapter 11,
that wisdom and understanding power and might knowledge and the fear of the
Lord, the Spirit at work. And we see that revealed,
we see that fulfilled in Christ's baptism as is anointing,
as the Spirit came down like a dove.
The Holy Spirit points to Christ in all things.
And we see him breathing out scripture throughout the prophets.
Earlier in Ezekiel two, um, God said to Ezekiel, in, in chapter two,
verse one through three says, son of man,
stand on your feet and I will speak with you. And as he spoke to me,
Ezekiel rights, the Spirit entered into me and set me on my feet.
And I heard him speaking to me. And he said to me, son of man,
I send you to the people of Israel,
to the nation of rebels who have rebelled against me.
We read later in second Peter that no prophecy
was ever produced by the will of man,
but men spoke from God as they were carried on by the Holy Spirit. You see,
Peter was talking about his own observations,
his own ways that he saw Christ.
But he says that we have seen the prophetic word more confirmed, more fulfilled,
even through scripture, through the Spirit at work.
And so this is the heritage of the spirit. This is, this is what the,
the disciples would've been able to see in their writings.
They would've seen the spirit of truth, the spirit of God,
the breath of God, the Holy Spirit at work all throughout the Old Testament.
And so they anticipated his coming.
They anticipated that promise of John chapter 14.
And in John chapter 16, where,
where God pro Jesus promises that he's gonna send another helper and
that a helper we're also bring to remembrance all that Jesus has taught.
And so as we go throughout the New Testament, we see the Holy Spirit convicting.
We see him helping and healing. We see Him counseling.
Paul writes that He prays for us when we can't pray for ourselves,
that he bears fruit in our lives.
He gives boldness to the followers of Christ and he guides us.
But let's jump back into Acts chapter two and see this work of the Spirit played
out in verse four
We're reminded. It says He filled all with the Holy Spirit.
All were filled with the Holy Spirit. Now that filled is saturated, right?
That's the, that's the fulfillment. When Christ said you would be baptized,
immersed, filled with, saturated with the Holy Spirit.
And then he goes about his work.
We know this story where the disciples were able to speak in all these different
languages and people that came from all these other countries could understand
as if in their own language. And they weren't just speaking about anything.
They weren't just speaking randomly.
They were speaking about the mighty works of God.
This was an undoubtedly a work of the Spirit. And then in this time,
Peter preaches his first sermon. He's empowered by the Holy Spirit.
And there's order that comes.
And Peter lifts his voice and he proclaims Christ.
He walks through this revelation.
He explains for these Jews that this is the revelation of Joel.
This is the pouring out of the spirit. It's not new wine.
And then he,
he reminds him of the words of David of the Messiah in Psalm 16,
and then proclaims that Jesus is that Messiah where he says,
I saw the Lord always before me.
He is at my right hand that I not may not be shaken. Therefore,
my heart was glad and my tongue rejoiced and my flesh will dwell in hope.
So he recites these words that would've resonated.
And through the spirit he has used to connect the Father to the Son,
he reveals to them that the Messiah that they were waiting is Christ who they
crucified. And he's very clear in that he doesn't pull any punches at all.
And then we get to verse 36, and Peter brings it home.
He says,
let all the house of Israel therefore know for certain that God has made him
both Lord and Christ, this Jesus whom you crucified.
Now we see a flip. We've seen the spirit working through Peter,
working through the disciples,
and now we see the Spirit at work and the hearers.
He says Now when they heard this, they were cut to the heart.
They were cut to their core.
And they said to Peter and the rest of the Apostles Brothers, what shall we do?
And Peter said to them, repent and be baptized.
You see, the Holy Spirit was at work and those hearers,
he was calling and convicting.
And Peter simply completes the truth of the gospel. He says,
repent and be baptized every one of you in the name of Jesus Christ for the
forgiveness of your sins. And you'll receive the same gift of the Holy Spirit.
This promise is for you and for your children and for all who are far off.
Everyone who calls on the name of the Lord our God.
And so this is the work of the spirit in the world.
He works through enabling and calling followers of Christ,
but he also works in those to whom he is speaking.
And so it is important. It's important that we know who the Holy Spirit is.
He is God. He's omnipotent, he's omniscient, he's wholly imperfect.
He's He's all those things.
And we see these actions of what He does. We see him call and convict.
We see him in dwell and illuminate. He helps and he heals.
We see in Titus that he regenerates and he renews. He points to Jesus,
the Prince of Peace. The Holy Spirit directs our desires.
He secures and he sanctifies us. He empowers us for proclamation
and all that's good. The work of the Spirit is good. And in Romans eight,
Paul tells us that the Spirit bears witness with our spirit.
He reminds us as followers that we did not receive the spirit of slavery to fall
back into fear.
But we've received the spirit capital s of adoption as
sons by whom we cry. Abba Father, the Spirit himself,
bears witness with our spirit.
And so we all have a personal testimony of how the Spirit has worked in our
lives. That as we look for the spirit at work in our lives,
we're gonna see him at work in our lives if we are indeed followers of Christ.
I can look back and see his call and conviction on my heart sitting on a cabin
floor at Sky Ranch Camp so many years ago.
And I,
I can remember the Holy Spirit speaking to me while I was pumping gas at a
7-Eleven on 15th and Western,
opening my heart to the truths of why he had moved our family to Oklahoma,
why he had guided and directed, and I didn't know why,
but then he revealed that
I remember the work of the Spirit in our family and mine and
Julie's hearts walking through a miscarriage that he helped. And he healed us.
He comforted us in that season.
I remember the work of the spirit sitting right back over here,
right where the hos are sitting,
speaking to my heart during a service and directing where I would go to serve in
Nicaragua and not move to another place.
And then I remember the work of the spirit,
him speaking to my heart and speaking through me to teach pastors in
Nicaragua. And if you had told me years before that I would ever be doing that,
I would've said, no way, Jose. But the Spirit works.
And he moves and he does.
Mighty works for proclamation and he promises to do the same.
But too often we miss it.
We miss the work of the Holy Spirit because we're not tuned in to what he's
doing. Some people, some churches, um,
think only about God the Father in this, in this otherness,
this reverence in all. And he's unapproachable and we get focused and,
and we can get dried out with that. And others might only focus on,
on Christ the Son. And he's our bro and our bff and first among brothers.
And we lose that reverent awe.
And others still might only focus on the spirit of what he might do for me,
what he might give me, how he might prophesy through me, heal me,
pour out on me. And Satan wants that division.
He wants us to,
to piecemeal out and lose sight of the perfect unity that is in God.
This triunity, the Trinity. You see the truth.
The reality is that God, the Father,
sent God the Son so that we might know him and be joined
back to him. And then God, the Son, sent the Spirit,
the Holy Spirit to be a permanent resident in our lives,
not coming and going,
but staying and filling to help and to counsel and to direct and
give life,
to point to Christ and to illuminate his word,
which is how we might know the Father. You see,
the Spirit calls people. And he's calling today,
he's calling me and he's calling you.
He called the followers in Jerusalem to repent and be
baptized. And that may be the call for some today to repent,
to turn from sin, to turn to Christ,
to allow that spirit of renewal and regeneration to work.
He may be calling you as followers of Christ to turn from sin
and trust in him, to turn from the world and the security of the world,
and trust in him as ultimate security.
And he may be calling us to simply kneel and to know,
to know God, to spend time at his feet,
to be filled with the spirit and then to proclaim his truth to those around us.
So this morning, as we go to the Lord in prayer,
as we sit at the feet of the cross of Christ,
as we open our hearts through the spirit,
let us pray and listen to how the Spirit might be calling.